Welcome to "Ear Biscuits",
a podcast where two lifelong
friends talk about life
for a long time.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we're going to be talking about
our relationship to Christmas
and how it has evolved over
time as we've evolved as people.
Yeah, it's an interesting touch point.
It's interesting for me.
This is kind of an exercise
of looking through the lens
of Christmas and seeing my former self
maybe in different stages
and then my current self.
That's how you see this going?
Yeah, I mean, you know.
This conversation, I mean.
Talking about, yeah, or just life.
Yeah, I mean I think I wanna talk about
the way that I used to
think about Christmas
and then as I was sort
of transitioning out
of personally considering
myself a Christian,
like what that was like and
then what it's like today.
And how that continues to be in process.
Yeah, this is gonna be interesting.
Who knows where this is gonna go?
One quick thing before we move on though.
Is it a podcast where two lifelong friends
or is it the podcast
where to lifelong friends?
I don't listen to any other
ones with two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
Because I think I've been saying the
but I could have sworn you said a.
Oh, did I? Okay.
I'd like to retract my a
and replace it with the the.
I don't know.
It was very quick.
The, I might say the.
You swallowed it a little bit.
I didn't really know.
I mean, but you made me think,
hold on, is it a or the?
What have I been saying?
I think I've been saying the.
We have to go to the tape.
Do we want to say the?
Let's say the?
The.
I might say the, I reserve
the right to say the.
Back to Christmas.
I mean this year in particular
and this approaching holiday season,
I mean, yes, we're gonna
be talking about Christmas
and there's gonna be-
I'm sorry to interrupt you
but you said two phrases
that make me think of Christmas movies.
You said the lens of Christmas
and I was like that would
be a good Christmas movie
then you said back to Christmas
and I was thinking about a future,
like a time travel movie.
"Back to the Future" Christmas edition?
You had to go back to
Christmas for something.
I really wanna make a
Christmas movie, man.
We should make a Christmas movie.
Well, the idea we came up
with for Christmas movie,
it just didn't, it didn't come together.
What was that idea?
It was called, it was it was about a gift.
It was about a gift that you,
it was a husband got a gift for his wife.
He wanted to get her the perfect gift.
It's called "The Perfect Gift."
Yes.
And I still think it's,
I think we could update
the idea and still make it.
I don't think it was a horrible idea
and a role for Jeff
Goldblum, remember that?
Yeah, he was-
Not that he would have ever said yes.
No, he was attached.
I wanna make a Christmas movie, man,
'cause I got to make a rec later on
and I was like I'm gonna rec
sort of like an under the radar
Christmas movie.
I got a great recommendation
for Christmas movie.
It's my favorite movie of all time.
Yeah, we know "Elf" so
I'm not gonna steal that
but I'm not gonna
recommend a Christmas movie
because there's just not,
I mean it's hard to find
the ones that are good.
When you ended up going
really quickly to "Die Hard"
as a Christmas movie, which
is not a Christmas movie.
It just takes place at Christmas,
it just shows you, there
just haven't been enough
good Christmas movies made.
We can give it another shot.
Come up with something
else or tweak that one.
And just another aside
about Jeff Goldblum,
I think this is something
that I just read on Reddit
as I was falling asleep.
Jeff Goldblum has this practice
whenever he meets somebody at a party,
well, the way it was described
was in a tweet from somebody
who was semi-famous, like a journalist
and who would mingle at parties
and he would know some people at parties
but he was introduced to Jeff
Goldblum for the first time
and the guy was introduced
to Jeff Goldblum.
Jeff Goldblum's first response
was, "Oh my god, of course!"
And it makes you feel important.
And he was like, I just didn't know how
but I guess Jeff Goldblum had read
one of my articles or something, you know?
He seemed to know me
but then, I happened to
hear him being introduced
to other people at the
party and every time,
he would say, "Oh my god, of course!"
You got to love that, man.
Yeah I mean it's a little manipulative
but it makes you feel good.
It's smart, it's smart.
It's makes you feel good.
People wanna be important.
I thought about maybe I should do that
or come on with my own version of that
and then I'm like, you know what,
you have to be Jeff Goldblum.
Well, I just think you have to change it.
You have to be Jeff Goldblum.
Not only change it from
what he says in particular.
Oh my god, of course!
But you have to change it,
maybe that was just that night.
Maybe when he's looking
at himself in the mirror
before he goes out, he's
like what is it tonight?
Oh my god, of course!
And then he goes with that.
Well, I think once you land on that one,
you realize it is the holy
grail of introduction responses
if you're Jeff Goldblum.
I mean, or someone else
who everybody at a party wants to talk to.
Like, not even just
because he's a celebrity,
because he's Jeff Goldblum.
What about, yes, finally?
I mean that-
Been waiting to meet you.
That has-
No, that doesn't work
because if you've already
met the person, doesn't work.
Oh my god, of course is the best
but I'm just saying you
don't wanna overuse it.
Back to Christmas.
Sorry, you were saying something.
Christmas this year along
with everything else this year
is strained and strange.
It's just a lot of traditions
are having to be altered
'cause the holiday season
is the time of tradition
but everything's got to change.
At least, for me, in my household,
we will not be going home for
Thanksgiving or Christmas.
I actually think by the
time this comes out,
Thanksgiving has already happened.
Yeah, it has.
And I did not go home
and I'm not going home
for the Christmas holidays or New Year's
or any of that stuff.
It's sad so I'm mourning
the ability to do that.
I am really relieved
that my extended family understands
and actually even before we told them,
I kinda felt like are we
breaking the news to them
that we're not coming home?
But when we had the discussions,
it was like, "Oh yeah, we already knew
that you guys weren't gonna
be able to come home."
It's just, you know.
I don't wanna get into what
the COVID numbers are like now
versus in a couple of weeks from now.
Well, they'll be higher
in a couple of weeks.
Oh, gosh.
I mean it's heading in the
wrong direction right now.
I've got loved ones that I wanna protect
and I just can't have,
I can't be the one that
increases their risk.
Hey, listen-
I just can't have that
on my conscience.
I don't necessarily wanna
go here but I will go here
because I know people feel
differently about this
but it is just a fact,
an indisputable fact
that some people this holiday
season will get on a plane,
go across the country to
be with their loved ones
and someone will die because of that.
I'm not saying-
Right.
I'm just saying that it's a
fact, that's gonna happen.
You can do with that what you
will and so for me, it's like-
That can't be on me.
I don't want to be a
part of that, you know?
I think next year is gonna be different.
I think we're gonna be through this
but I don't want the risk.
I'm just really glad that
they were expecting it,
they were on the same page,
they were understanding.
I mean that doesn't mean
it's not gonna be sad
and it's gonna hurt when
New Year rolls around
and we still haven't seen anybody.
It's gonna hurt but that's our plan.
The last two years, I actually think
this will be the third year, yeah.
So the last two years-
'Cause you've been going
home for Thanksgiving.
We've been going home for Thanksgiving
and not Christmas because we,
and I discussed this in this venue,
we had made a point that you know what,
we wanna start forging our own-
Swords.
traditions here in our home base so that,
I've really started to look forward
to what when my kids are coming
back home for the holidays
to me and Christy and then hopefully,
at one point, we got grandkids coming in.
We want our home that we set up
and the traditions that we
have to be the focal point
of this next layer of tradition, you know?
if you keep going home,
it's kinda stalls thing out
and that's kind of the decision we made
so we give them Thanksgiving
and then we don't give them Christmas,
at least until we can establish something
and that actually is
part of the complexion
of this conversation, I think,
is this being the third year,
we've got these COVID
complications and limitations
but still, the Neal family
were trying to forge
what Christmas looks
like for us in California
because traditions and
habits and expectations
aren't formed in just a year or two
and we're only in year three
so we're still trying
to figure all that out
and then you factor in
everything that, yeah,
you were talking about
just in terms of like
where I'm at spiritually that journey
and how all of that really
seems to come into sharp focus
around Christmas for obvious
Jesus as a baby reasons.
Would you say that you
home in on those things?
Did I say home?
No, I'm just saying that
you said sharp focus.
You're really the verbiage police today.
No, I'm-
The, the, a.
You didn't say anything.
It's just throwback, it's a
throwback to our conversation.
I thought I said-
You did not say anything.
Oh, I thought I said.
Yeah, and this Christmas is gonna be
especially interesting because
we're gonna spend it together
which we have not done.
You're talking about us now, me and you.
As families, we will be spending,
I'm not saying that we're necessarily
gonna get together on Christmas Day but-
We haven't made plans-
We don't know exactly what's
the ins and outs of this are
but the family that my
family is going to see
is your family, right?
And so, and we haven't done that before
because we typically do go home
to North Carolina for Christmas
and have the traditions
that we do with my family and
then with Jessie's family.
They all kind of live
really close to one another
and they do, obviously,
they want us to come back
but they also probably know
that given our disposition
when it comes to the
pandemic that we will not be.
And yeah, so it's gonna be
strange because we haven't,
we don't have these traditions
that we've done as a family on our own.
There's only been one Christmas
in all of our time in California
where we didn't go home
And it's like Jessie's birthday
is a week before Christmas
and then what we typically would do,
we would celebrate her birthday
and then like that weekend
before Christmas, usually,
get on the plane and go to North Carolina.
So being here for the whole time
and then also, usually,
we tack on like a trip
for ourselves as a family
after we get done with the
Christmas and the New Year stuff.
Like right at the beginning of the year
and you've this as well,
it might just be me and Jessie
going somewhere together
like for a few days but
none of that's gonna happen.
There's just gonna be a
whole lot of being at home
through this whole time
and I really don't know
how to prepare for it.
We'll make the best of it.
At least we do have our families
that we're in this quarantine
pod situation and that helps.
and then our friend Mike and his family.
We're gearing up
to make sure that like
we're in a safe situation
to pod up with them.
I'm pretty sure they'll
be here for the holidays
and so it'll be like our three families.
Yeah, so I think it will be a good time
being safe together.
I'm looking forward to it.
Oh, it'll be a good time.
But we've got to kind of invent our,
I mean first of all, I'm very excited
about the food, of course,
and I wanna play an integral part
in the preparation of the food.
I've got several ideas.
Oh, yeah.
That I'll actually get into
when I do my rec later on but.
I plan to feed you, that's
what I'm saying ultimately.
And I could still contribute
music on a playlist.
Yeah, you can have a playlist.
You had a great playlist the other night.
That worked, right?
Yeah.
You know, I was able to,
whenever something needed
to be said important,
I stop the music.
Yeah.
And then when it was over,
I started the music back
and then people were
like, oh I like this song.
It's like, your music's a little too loud,
can you turn it down?
Oh, sure, sure.
And while I was outside
frying up the chicken
for the Nashville hot chicken sandwiches,
I was listening to the
music outside as well.
I had it pumping outside
so I was hearing the playlist
just by myself and I was-
Kinda bopping?
I was kinda move in a little bit.
You're kinda moving?
And Mike brought me a couple of drinks
which made everything better.
Yeah, there you go.
So, we all have our part to play.
Okay, well now, I'm just
thinking about that.
I might dress up like Santa.
Maybe could get, I don't know,
somebody could dress up like Santa.
Well, I kinda think-
We could do a nativity scene.
I feel like in our pod
that, Mike is probably the-
He's got the whitest beard.
He got the whitest beard.
We got this-
We'll talk about it.
Last year-
You wanna be an elf.
Last year, when you guys were here-
That's what you like so much.
I'll do it.
With Mike and Mike's family and Jenny,
we got matching Christmas pajamas.
We all wore matching Christmas pajamas.
Well, is that happening again?
It should.
Do I have to buy the same
pair that you already have
or are we're going all new?
I'd like to just reuse what I have
but I haven't thought about it.
You got to see if you can acquire it.
I guess something that's
a close approximation
but a little bit better.
But is there gonna be a nativity scene?
Are we gonna have like
a little Baby Jesus?
Are we gonna have like goats and sheep?
Back home, there was,
you drive by a church and they
would have built this like
three-sided shack made
out of like pallet wood
and then there'd be people dressed up
like Mary, Joseph and a baby.
There'd be a frigging-
Hold on, you've been a part
of a live nativity with me.
I've not been a part of a live
nativity, like been in it?
As a youth group.
Very young.
Hold on, weren't you Joseph?
I could have sworn that you were Joseph
and I was a shepherd.
I may have been Joseph
one year early on, yeah.
Yeah, it was cold.
I just remember it was
cold and I was like,
man, I just got on like-
I don't remember-
I don't have enough clothes on.
I thought it was inside.
See, I'm not even remembering this right.
There was a live nativity
at Buies Creek First Baptist Church
that the youth did.
And Maria Matthews was Mary.
I think that was a play and it was inside.
There was like a Christmas cantata.
Okay, well, I could have sworn
there was a live nativity.
There was not a real baby though.
I haven't done it as an adult
because now, I would be an
amazing shepherd with my beard.
You're too tall.
No, no, no, I'm too tall for Joseph.
Let's get real here.
I'm too tall for Joseph,
that would be a distraction
but having one tall ass
shepherd or one tall ass-
Wise man.
I think you'd be a wise man
'cause they're walking
from a long distance.
They're following that star.
Yeah, a wise man.
I wanna be the one with the frankincense.
And if you wanna be right about it-
Or I wanna be the merman.
The Wise Men is not gonna
show up for like years, right?
He didn't show up when the baby was born.
Well, now, you're
getting into some of the,
some of the complex questions
around the historicity
of the nativity story.
Let's come back to this.
We'll talk about in a second.
We'll talk about all that but first,
we do wanna let you know
that whether you're traveling
or not this Christmas,
you can get a travel mug-
Look at this thing.
from mythical.com.
It's tall, it's cylindrical.
It fits in any cup holder in
your car and travels with you.
You might get excited about a travel mug
and you wait for it to show up,
you unbox it you wash it
or maybe you just put your beverage in it
and you're like screw it,
I'm just gonna drink it.
That's my version of washing it.
And then you put it in your car
and it won't fit in your cup holder.
Not with this one.
Big fail.
This thing will fit.
It's got a nice secure top on it
that pops open and it pops open in a way
that you don't have to touch
the place where your lips go.
And it's open in a way
that it doesn't hit you in
the nose when you drink it.
Yep, see that?
We thought through all this.
See that? It's nice.
Now, it's hard to read what it says
but it says "Good Mythical Morning".
But you knew that anyway.
With Rhett and Link.
And maybe you like it that way.
I like it that way.
Mythical.com.
Get yourself a travel mug
even if you can't travel.
Okay, Christmas.
I kind of-
♪ Christmas ♪
I sort of see this-
I kinda see this as, for me
and I think for you as well
just because we've been on
really similar journeys.
I mean, there's some different stages
and of course, the first stage
is what Christmas is like
when you are a Christian.
Let's roll out.
If you have idea of stages,
just get roll out to stages
just so I know where you're going.
Okay, stage one is Christmas
when you're a Christian
and when I say Christian,
I mean a Bible-believing,
in our case, evangelical Christian
that takes the Christmas
story 100% literal truth.
That's stage one.
Stage two is a Christian
who is struggling with doubt
engaging with Christmas.
Stage three is someone who would no longer
call themselves a Christian
engaging with Christmas.
And you might think, isn't
that the all three stages?
I think for me, there's
a fourth stage which is-
Well, but you can maybe
be suspenseful about that.
There's a fourth stage.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm just gonna say
it's the way that I am hoping
to engage with Christmas now.
Mm, I'm very-
Which maybe be surprising.
I'm very interested in this.
I think in anticipation
of this conversation,
a number of thoughts come up for me,
some of which I don't wanna process here,
honestly, because I don't want
this to be the first place
that I processed this type of thing
because it implies
inviting people to weigh in
or help me figure things out for myself
and I'm making the decision
that I'm trying to put some boundaries
on what I'm processing
publicly and privately
and so some of that's coming up here
but I'm still very excited
to talk about this.
And we tend to we tend to
approach these type of things
and think about them in different ways.
If you look back at our
deconstruction stories,
they're unique to each of us in the way
that we've grappled with our faith
and that we've moved
forward in our journeys.
I take great comfort in the fact
that we are moving forward in our journeys
and that we have different approaches.
I really enjoy the fact
that like I haven't thought
about these stages that you
just mentioned so I'm kinda,
but I have my own thoughts
that I'll pepper in there
and might choose to keep my
mouth shut at other times
but we'll see how it plays out.
And I do, anytime we talk about,
and we what about spiritual
things more freely
since breaking the seal with
our conversation earlier
in the year about our
spiritual deconstruction
and these are sensitive topics
that mean a lot to a lot of people.
People hold these things very
near and dear to their hearts
for obvious reasons
and so, just disclaimer
as we talk about these things,
I just wanna be very clear
that nothing I'm gonna say
or I'll speak for Link as well,
is meant to be prescriptive.
This is not advice.
This isn't how we think you
should approach Christmas.
This isn't what we think is right for you.
This is our process.
This is just our personal story
of what it was like at
those different stages.
You may relate to some of it, you may not.
You may disagree with
some of the conclusions.
I'm not trying to get you to
come to a different conclusion.
It's just this is a story.
That applies to every
conversation we have here
but with a sensitive topic like this,
I'm glad that us said-
Yeah, I feel like-
'Cause it's like we're
literally just processing
our lives in this venue.
Well, sometimes we do give
prescriptive advice to people
if they ask for it.
Sometimes, if they don't ask for it
but it's usually about things
that don't really matter.
Right, that's when we
feel most comfortable.
If we can help it.
So we're gonna stay a
little cagey but honest.
Okay, so again, for
what still remains to be
the majority of the life
that I've lived so far,
I was an evangelical Christian.
Someone who believes that the Bible
is the inerrant, that means
without error word of God
and so that means that
the Christmas story itself
of God taking the form of a baby human,
of a virgin becoming
pregnant with that baby human
and that baby human being God himself
and also God's son in the form of Jesus
coming to the Earth to offer a pathway
of reconciling people to God.
That's what we thought and we thought
that's what Christmas is for
an evangelical Christian.
It is the story of Jesus's birth.
And is it Jesus's or is it Jesus birth?
I've heard pastors say it both ways.
Don't get hung up.
I'm gonna say Jesus's
just because you can tell
that I'm saying it's possessive.
The story of Jesus's birth.
And I think it's just an interesting thing
in our culture in America.
I guess this happens in other places
but there's like this longstanding thing
that happens between,
like there's the Merry Christmas people
and there's the happy holidays people
and there's like this
battle line that's drawn
and like people get mad at Starbucks
if they don't say Merry
Christmas or whatever, right?
And this is a relatively
recent sort of cultural battle
but I remember what I
can relate to about this
is I remember as a Christian and listen,
a Christian who was like working
for a Christian organization full-time,
like taking it very seriously.
I always thought that this
little cultural infighting
about the whole Merry Christmas thing,
I was like why are y'all
getting so upset about this?
Yeah, I mean-
I've never related to it.
I think another way that
we might've put it was,
'cause I agree that was
my assessment at the time,
was like this is not a good look.
This is not the-
This is not the battle
that we should be fighting.
What is your desired
outcome from this battle?
That some atheist somewhere
would say yes, you're right.
Merry Christmas.
Is that what we're trying to accomplish?
It felt like a turf war,
like protecting your turf
and again, I was like very
much on board for Jesus
is the reason for the season.
'Cause it rhymes?
It looks great in a store window.
Yeah, a couple of months ago,
we were we were driving past this,
all my family was in the
car and we drove past,
I guess it was October
and on automobile lot
and they got the showroom
with like the big glass windows
and they paint all their
windshields with prices
but they painted their
showroom windows huge
across all the windows.
Like if you had really
take the time to back up
or really take in the whole thing,
across the whole thing, it said
Jesus is the reason for the season
and then it was October.
They had never taken it down.
So I'm like-
Well.
Well, kids you know what? It's fall.
Jesus is the reason for the season.
Jesus is the reason for fall.
And technically,
that's true.
It maybe right.
I mean from that perspective.
So yeah, so we didn't really
get in on that bandwagon
and to me, it felt silly
when I saw Christians
getting really concerned
about that particular issue.
Even though for us personally,
Jesus was absolutely
the center of Christmas,
which was the main holiday
that we were personally celebrating.
Yeah, and the way that I relate to-
There are other holidays that
are happening around then
that other people celebrate, you know?
So just say happy holidays
just to acknowledge
that other people are
celebrating other holidays
is not a bad thing.
That's just called being considerate.
Right, it seems very Christian, actually.
So I just never got that.
I'm glad.
I mean there's lots of things I'm like
I wish I would've done it differently
but I never fought that fight.
Yeah, but the thing that-
I never insisted that
somebody else celebrate
something that I'm celebrating.
Right, right but the
thing that I can relate to
when it comes to this
maybe holding Christmas
in a precious way
is the secular treatment of Christmas,
just traditionally, right?
So you've got like okay,
you've got Charles Dickens
as an example, right?
So you've got "A Christmas Carol"
or really anything that centers
around the spirit of Christmas
as it relates to anything
other than Jesus.
So you've got Santa and gift-giving and-
Well, gift-giving, you
could say that the tree,
some people say the tree is Pagan,
some people say the tree is Christian,
some people say gift-giving-
You can come and do all these things
for your individual purposes
but what I'm saying is that like,
I wasn't one of these
anti-Santa Christians either
and not in like a Santa
is just Satan rearranged
in the same letters, right?
Like there are Christians who think that
and think that Santa is
this secular distraction.
I didn't think that either
but what I did think is when
I would see a Christmas movie,
let's say "Elf" as an
example, your favorite movie.
Best movie ever.
I could appreciate how
awesome of a movie it is,
not necessarily my
favorite even in my top 10
but a very solid Christmas movie.
I could appreciate it and appreciate
all the good principles that
it kinda, that it reinforced
in the spirit of Christmas
but as a Christian,
I would kinda stand aside
and say yeah, that's a real nice story
but you guys do know
that Jesus is the reason for the season,
that the whole point of this holiday
is to celebrate the fact
that God became a human,
came down on our level and gave us a way
to be reconciled to him.
You do understand that's what's it about.
Well, and it's one thing to imply it
in all of the Hollywood Christmas movies
but I mean, in a lot of
times, it's blatantly stated
that the reason for the season
or they may put it in different terms
but they'll blatantly say
that like the spirit
of Christmas is family.
It's like good tidings.
Right.
It's I'll be home for Christmas,
it's getting together.
It's that type of stuff.
And I didn't want people
to change their movies.
I wasn't thinking like,
"Elf" would have been a
whole lot better if like,
if the, what's the elf's name?
You should know this.
Will Ferrell.
Well, what's his name in the movie?
Buddy.
If Buddy would have become a
Christian during the movie,
like I'm not talking about like,
I'm not saying I wanna have
like Kirk Cameron type movies.
I wasn't into that.
No, no, no, we hated those.
We hated those.
We hated those movies.
We hated movies that
were explicitly Christian
and had but-
Because they weren't artful.
Yeah.
Most, all of them.
Again, it felt like
it was for the audience but anyway,
or it was preaching to
the choir, whatever.
But I still had this sort
of judgment in my mind
that was like, yeah,
you guys almost get it
but you don't really get it.
You've created all this
holiday accoutrement
around Christmas in order
to make it seem meaningful
but you've missed the heart of it
which is this is about Jesus y'all.
And so, it's all pointless, ultimately.
If you're gonna miss the heart of it,
then all this stuff around, it
really doesn't mean anything.
I was very sensitive to putting my values
and expectations onto other people
that I didn't think I had
any realistic expectation
that they will be interested in that.
But I'll tell you what I did do.
Yeah, I mean, as a kid,
our evangelical upbringing
was like the center point of our identity.
I mean, and then
I think for me, there had to be like
looking down my nose at other people
or just maybe feeling sorry for people
who are just missing like the real point
of what needs to be
celebrated at Christmas
and what I'm experiencing and celebrating.
It was more of a bless
their hearts kinda thing.
Yeah, there was a depth in the experience
that I was having that I felt like,
by comparison, from my
evangelical perspective
looking at other people, just thinking,
okay, it's just a bit, it's a bit shallow.
Yeah, I mean like family
and love and service
and all these good things are,
they're very meaningful things
but they're not as meaningful as God
coming to Earth, humbling
himself as a baby.
Like that's tremendously inspirational
and a lot of other things.
And then when when
Christy and I got married
and we started having kids,
it's like, okay, now,
it's my opportunity to,
I'm in charge of creating new traditions
and finding the ways that
we're gonna keep Jesus
at the center of our focus.
And so one of the things
we did is we would,
we made up our mind that we
were gonna always tell our kids
that and maybe we need to put
a spoiler alert on this but-
I don't-
You know what I'm about to say.
If there's somebody listening
that you don't wanna
know certain things that-
About the man, the
secular man of Christmas?
Yeah.
We're gonna reveal the truth
about the secular man of Christmas
so if you have a little ones
who are listening in on this conversation
and you want the miracle of
Christmas to remain alive,
tune out right now.
This what's happening right here
was never a problem for
me because I decided.
I think this was a Link decision.
It's like, you know what,
our kids are always gonna know
that Santa is just is fake
but we're still gonna have,
we're still gonna surprise
them with presents
on Christmas morning that weren't
wrapped in under the tree.
There's gonna be some unwrapped stuff
that's gonna be there when
they run down the stairs
and I still wanna have that scene
because it's so exciting
and I don't wanna take that away entirely.
But when the weatherman
is like we've spotted Santa on the radar.
I'd be like, kids, that's BS.
When Lily's five years
old, she never thought,
there was never a point where she thought
and she knew that she wasn't
supposed to tell other kids
and unlike you who told me
way too late in my experience
that Santa Claus was fake,
she did not do that to her
friends at a young age.
Well, the funny thing about this
is that I never made a
decision one way or the other.
I always, you know me,
I like making things up,
making my kids believe
things that aren't true
just for my own personal entertainment.
And so Santa, it fits
the bill there, right?
And so we would-
Your Santa probably was real crazy.
Well, the thing is is that-
Like he's got three eyes but
one of them has an eye patch.
But think about my kids though.
My kids are just like me and I didn't,
the reason I didn't think Santa was real
when I was a kid wasn't
because an adult told me,
it was because-
Are you saying you're
smarter than me as a kid?
Well, no, I think about
things in a different way,
let's just say that.
I was like this can't be real.
I embraced the wonder and joy of life
and I don't question it.
And so my kids did the exact same thing.
There was never a moment
where I had to break a truth to them.
It was more just like at
some point, at an early age,
they were just like, "I
know Santa is not real.
I know you're giving me these gifts."
I had made a-
But it's fun to play along.
I'd made a decision to
actually proactively tell them
and like burst the bubble
before it would hurt too bad.
The reason why I actually felt really good
about saying this is a protection from,
even for my kids at their youngest age,
I'm removing some of the temptation
to focus on the wrong thing.
It's like remember, we're
focusing on Jesus here.
We can have the presents
and the reason why we have the presents
was because presents were brought to Jesus
because people knew that
he was God incarnate
and they were they came
to worship him as a king
and they gave him gifts.
And so, you just try to couch everything
through the lens of Jesus, right?
That's a Christmas movie for Kirk Cameron.
Right, through the lens of Jesus.
And I felt good about that.
Now, I don't feel bad
about it now but I just,
I was kind of a stickler
but I remember feeling like
this is something tangible
that I've done that impacts
my family's ability to focus
on what matters most.
Well, and some people-
And I think that that was my role.
And some people might
say just another reason
if this is your perspective.
Another reason to clarify
the fact that Santa
is a made up thing is
because you don't want it
to be like, all right,
there's two things that are true, child.
Jesus is God's son and God in the flesh
is the Christmas story
but also, there's this
dude named Saint Nicholas
who comes and flies
around, hauled by reindeer
and gives you presents.
Flying reindeer and
comes down your chimney.
At some point, I'm gonna
break the news to you
that one of these two things is not real.
And the way I'm gonna do it
is by saying one of these
is not real, you choose.
Right, yeah.
No, but you don't-
Yeah, and so for, I think,
for some Christians,
it's like hey, let's
tell our kids the truth,
and again, this is the truth
according to a Christian,
that hey, this story is real
and this story is sort of
the secular cultural story
that we tell ourselves
with sort of a fairytale
like the like the Tooth Fairy,
whatever Easter Bunny, you know?
And they never believed the Easter Bunny
or the Tooth Fairy really either
for kind of the same reason.
Easter Bunny is-
I have this principle like you know what,
I don't wanna have to break it to my kids
that I was lying to 'em.
I don't know that that's
how kids but is say-
I never went there 'cause I
lie to my kids all the time
but the Easter Bunny is
the worst holiday mascot
because what does the Easter Bunny do?
I mean the Tooth Fairy
has a very specific thing.
It's a transactional relationship.
You give him the tooth,
he gives you money.
I understand how that works.
I know when it happens.
Are you picturing The Rock or something?
You're saying he.
Well, I'm saying he because
I played the Tooth Fairy
in a video I'm very proud of.
Do you remember that video that we made?
I can't remember what it's called.
Spot the differences?
Spot the differences, whatever.
But the Easter Bunny,
no one says, hey, let's go
outside and find the eggs
that the Easter Bunny hid.
We do away with that mirage.
We say no, the parents are going outside.
What is the role of the Easter Bunny?
I think to be eating his
chocolate, I don't know.
Yeah, it's a weak ass,
weak ass holiday mascot.
I will say there was another factor
in saying that Santa Claus wasn't real
but they still got the gifts
because then I could take full
credit for all of the gifts.
I understand that.
I think that was an ulterior
motive on my behalf.
But yeah, there was this, I mean I was,
we had so many family to visit
that We didn't go to the
Christmas Eve service.
We didn't actually have a lot of like
Christmas time traditions
but we did have some,
like we would read like
from the children's Bible
like the Christmas story from a young age.
I've got this video of Lily
before she could read,
we had read it to her so
much that she had memorized
the Christmas story based on
this children's picture book
and it's cutest thing
because she would act like she's reading
but she just memorized
everything that we said per page.
And it felt good to know
that one of the first things
she memorized was the story
of Jesus humbling himself
and coming to Earth
in order to be her savior.
I just felt like I was,
okay, I was like this is my job as dad
and Christy's job as mom is
to instill this knowledge
in her at a young age to where
she knows that God loves her
and cares about her and
went to great lengths
to not only demonstrate that
but to make that relationship possible.
So it felt really good and
it was it was validating
that we've got this system,
I've got this belief system
that I'm all in with and I'm very,
every benefit associated with it.
I felt like I was, at the time,
that I was only experiencing the benefits.
I think I've processed in my other story
that like there there's
another side to it for me
but at Christmas time, it felt good.
It's like okay, we're not
losing sight of the point.
Yeah.
Most of our touch points
related to church.
We were very involved in our church.
You were very involved
in your church as well
but during Christmas, we
were very involved in church
including like being
involved in the program
to the point where every year, Jesus,
Jessie, my wife, would put would
play Mary in this like play
and I think maybe for
the first year she did it
or one year she did it,
like Locke was Jesus
but other years, it was
other people's babies,
like a real baby.
She would sing.
Ah.
Like, she's like this
one woman show as Mary.
And you'd light candles and
it would be a big moment.
The Advent and then there was that album,
that dude, what is his name?
Is it Andrew Peterson? Is that his name?
I don't know if that's the-
I don't know.
I don't know if,
there's this guy.
He's the Christian musician
who came out with the album
that has become the all the
songs that Christians play.
It's been like 15 years
ago and it's just like...
It's not "Mary, Did You
Know?", that's the old school.
This is like it's the one
about like Mary in the...
The whole album is a Christmas album
and it's the one where like all the things
that people singing and
evangelical churches come from.
And I think this dude's name is Peterson.
And you know these songs for 100% sure
'cause you were a music
leader at your church.
You just didn't maybe make
the connection to the album.
I was the hip.
I assume they're still,
I know they're still playing them
because when I went to
a Christmas Eve service
at my old church like two years ago,
it's still playing the same songs.
So what is your point?
I'm just saying that,
that was just a complete sidebar
but my point is is that
all our touch points
were related to like the
Christmas Eve service
and the things leading up to Christmas
that we did as a church and
it was all very meaningful
and it was all very personal and impactful
and we were involved as a family.
Well, let's move on to stage two, right?
Because as we've established,
that mentality and that
approach did not continue.
For me, I struggled with doubt
pretty much my entire adult life
as it related to my Christian faith
but probably about 15 years ago or so
was when the doubts began to get
kind of crippling to the point that
engaging in like Bible
reading as an example,
would inflame my doubts, right?
So if I would go to the Bible
to have my doubts addressed,
some of the other things that I had read
about these particular
things would enter my mind
and it became this thing
where the more sensational the story,
the more difficult it
was for me to believe
and I feel like the Christmas story
kind of brings together a lot
of different elements, right?
So you've got some things that are,
let's just be honest,
difficult to believe.
Virgin birth, the idea that there's a star
that is settling over
the town of Bethlehem
that is leading the Wise Men to the town
which seems to indicate
that the authors didn't really understand
the nature of stars and how
far away they actually are
and how that's not how stars work
or maybe it was a special star
that was just happened for this.
Listen, everything that
I'm gonna say right now,
which is sort of like my doubts
that I have about the story,
I am well aware that there are plenty
of evangelical traditional
Christian explanations
for all these things.
I'm not discounting those.
I'm just saying that for me,
when I engage with the Christmas story
from a historical perspective
and some of the issues
that there are there
related to like the Herod
and the governor of Syria Quirinius
or the census and these things
that like you can kind
of call into question
from a historical perspective
and the way that they line up
or the fact that the Christmas story,
the nativity story is kinda
added to Luke and Matthew
but it's not in the earliest
gospel, the Book of Mark
so it kinda lends itself to this idea
that the legend of Jesus
was growing as time went by
and so they were adding things
like hey, let's add this story
that shows how he fulfilled prophecy.
Again, this is the secular
view of these things.
And I began to see some of those answers
and some of those explanations
to those difficult passages
less as a good answer and
more as what felt like
this seems more desperate, right?
It's not satisfying to me
and so when I would engage with the story,
I would be thinking
about all those things.
It's like I'm thinking about
the critical view of this story
which is not a fun way to
engage with a story, right?
And so, Christmas became a time
where I was kind of two minds, right?
There was some serious
cognitive dissonance going on
because there was a real appreciation
for the idea of Christmas and the idea
that God would become one of us
and would make that connection in a way
that I had not seen demonstrated
in any other faith system, right?
And there was all the stuff
that went along with it
and those songs that
we sang from that album
that I can't remember.
They were incredibly meaningful
even in the middle of my
severe doubt about these things
When I would read the story
and these doubts would be inflamed,
I could still move on
to singing the songs,
singing the hymns, thinking about Jesus
and it would be very
moving and very impactful
but there was a few, a
good number of years there
where the doubts were so strong
that engaging with the story of Christmas
was bit of a train wreck inside my mind.
Yeah, I can understand what you're saying.
I think in my process, Christmas
didn't bring up as much
but it didn't,
it wasn't as difficult
because there was more
like the traditions that we had
and the amount of family we had to visit,
it was easier to get distracted
and I felt like I tended to
focus on the expectations
that I had placed on myself
to make sure that like
we're remembering that
Jesus is the center of this
and we're doing some
things and we do have some,
we have the Advent calendar
and we have traditions that
we're doing with the kids
but it was easy personally, I think,
as there were starting to be doubts
for me just to go into distraction mode
'cause there was so much
else going on anyway
in terms of gifts and family
and food and everything else
that is the secular reasons for the season
that everybody falls back on.
Right.
I definitely remember
you talking about albums.
At a certain point when I was,
I mean our conversations were
pretty constant and so my,
I was more resistant at first
because I didn't wanna shake things up
but as as I started to come
to grips with my own doubts
and my own experience, I
remember at Christmas time,
I would listen to Sufjan
Stevens' Christmas albums.
Like for a couple of years,
he would release one every year
so there's like this four-disc
box set that as a family,
it's still very much a
tradition for us to listen.
This is the album that's
playing in our house constantly
and I would recommend getting it
if you're a fan of Sufjan's earlier stuff.
His stuff now-
I can't get into it.
It's like-
I tried to get into it-
I don't know what you need to be
under the influence of but-
Well, it just went, it went-
It's very electronic.
He went electronic and
I'm just not into that.
So this like acoustic homemade,
feels like four track in his
own house like playing horns
and having people who can't sing
start to sing along with him and like-
Yeah, it was awesome.
It's really awesome but I
remember like thinking okay,
if Sufjan, he's singing
these Christmas songs
because he's got a Christian faith.
I don't know his story but like
he's got this faith in Jesus
and I don't know, I'm not
gonna put a label on him.
I don't know what label he
is applies to himself if any
or how that's changed over
the years but he made,
he released meaningful Christmas music
that was meaningful to me
and I thought this guy,
he seems really progressive,
he's an artist, he's cool.
I think maybe this is my future.
Maybe there's something
in his relationship
with Christmas and with Jesus
that like I could be like,
I could take a cue from
Sufjan Stevens, you know?
It's interesting, it's
like I'm not gonna read
as many books as you, I'm
just gonna start listening
to this guy and he
started saying if he can-
The thing about music though,
I think, this is an interesting point
and I agree with it and
relate to it personally
because music kinda transcends
the intellectual doubts
that you might have
and you're dealing with this
stuff that's kind of up here
in your head space and there's a rational
sort of battle that's happening?
Music connects with your
soul in a different way
and this is why I can
still listen, even today,
I don't consider myself a Christian,
I can listen to "Be Thou My Vision",
one of my favorite hymns and cry.
You know what I'm saying?
So, yeah there's something that transcends
that mental barrier in music
anyway so I think that was,
and I think it keeps, honestly,
it keeps people around for longer.
There's something about
just singing together.
I mean what other venue
do you have in your life
where you go and you get together
with a bunch of like-minded people
and you sing songs that are
just the most passionate things
you could possibly imagine?
I mean that doesn't happen.
Christians got that one down pretty good.
I mean, the closest
thing that I can think of
is when we went to our friend's house
and we did the sing along last year.
Oh, you didn't even come to that.
You guys didn't come.
You've totally missed out, man.
Thank you.
But like, we just sang.
It was like singing together.
I was like, man, singing-
That was a Thanksgiving thing, I think.
Singing together with other people,
it's just something that
should happen in more places.
But anyway, I digress.
So there was that period
where there was that
cognitive dissonance happening
and it was just like I
can't engage with this
but I love my family And I still love God
and I'm trying to figure
all this stuff out.
And then there was, again,
I told all the story,
I don't remember the exact year.
It was after we moved out here
when it became like official
but still, more than several years ago
where I was like okay, it's official,
I don't believe this anymore.
Like I cannot honestly
call myself a Christian.
I'm not going to pursue this,
I'm not going to engage with this,
I'm not gonna go to church anymore.
It wasn't that clean but there was a point
in which that was who I became.
But you still got Christmas rolling around
every single year, right?
And it's weird.
It's weird when you have like,
hey, we've been doing this every year
and it's been just saturated in meaning.
It's been saturated in the most
sort of consequential
and important meaning
that it could possibly have
and now, you're just gonna
become one of those guys
that's just getting through
the Christmas season
on some good tidings from
the Christmas movies?
For somebody who's had a really
deep spiritual experience,
those Christmas movies,
again, "Elf", great movie, doesn't cut it.
If you've had that depth of experience-
God is not a character.
Will Ferrell is awesome but he is not God.
And so, it's like you come to that time
and there's this like, man,
the depth of experience
and the depth that this
had associated with it
that permeated my life personally
but also permeated the lives
of my wives and children.
Wife and-
Watch out, man.
My wife and children.
Our family, that's an easier
way to say it, is not there.
How do you engage with that?
I think about the realization
that that children's book that we had,
it's like one year you pull
down the Christmas decorations
and the Christmas books
and like that book that Lily memorized
that you read with Lincoln
some when he was younger
that like you realize that
like you can't find it
in the box anymore or I don't remember
ever deciding to not
pull it out of the box
or not to read it to
Lando but it's like yeah,
it's just kinda like you
realize, you know what,
Lando never read this
book or and I remember,
I think I do remember Christy finding it
and reading it to Lando at a young age
and it was like, it wasn't
this communal experience
that it was before because we were
in this transitional time.
And again, it kind of the Christmas season
brought it into focus and part of it is
while you look at the other,
there's still a lot to be distracted by
and we're still going home for Christmas
and there's a lot of logistics involved
and it was once we moved out here, so,
it didn't feel like this painful moment.
It was just like all of a sudden,
you realize that book's not coming out
of the box anymore, you know?
And I do think, for me, that,
and that still, even now,
like I'm at a different phase
than I was that was like
everything seemed to be changing
much more rapidly in terms of my worldview
and my belief paradigm in my allegiance
to the evangelical worldview.
You get to a point and
it's like you come to grips
with that's not me anymore
and it's not changing as fast
but there's still this residual
in the back of my mind, I think.
I guess I would just call it,
there's an experience of guilt.
It's like because there's this questions.
It's like when you let,
as you put it in your story,
you jump ship you let go of something
but you don't have anything
specific to grasp onto.
It's like we're not now
ascribing to some other
religious belief system.
Well, and-
So, I do think for me,
there is a bit of,
yeah, it's like did I
make the right decision?
Did we as a family make a right decision?
It's like, there's these little questions.
It's like, I've tried my
best to embrace uncertainty
as a positive but there's
still moments of struggle
and I think it happens
more around the holidays
when you realize that like something
that was extremely meaningful
in a practice that you
have with your first child
is not part of what happens
with your third child
and are are they missing out?
Have we done them a disservice?
And then I kinda have to rederive
what brought me to this point
and also, look at our
children and how tremendously
fabulous they are and
how proud I am of them
and start to just have this
reality check that like okay,
these feelings of guilt or obligation,
sometimes, I think I would describe it
as I'm feeling judged by my former self
because the position I'm in now in the way
that I interact with Christmas
is something that, again, I said earlier,
I'd feel for people that they didn't have
the depth of experience that I have
and now, I'm in that position.
Mm-hm, yeah, and I mean I
definitely relate to that.
I mean, guilt is not really my,
that's not my thing as much.
Always my thing.
But there is a-
And I'm not blaming it all
on evangelicalism either.
It's a Link thing, it wasn't
created by the church.
It was just how-
Exacerbated by it.
Yeah.
I think that the, really
what you're getting at
is one of the things you're doing
is you're highlighting the
importance of religion, right?
You're highlighting the
importance of a spiritual life
and so, because if that meaning
is to be had from something,
if you can find that meaning
and that purpose in something,
well, that's one of the
reasons that religion exists.
That's one of the really,
that's the main reason that
people stick around for it
even if they don't quite
believe it in full, right?
If they have some doubts,
they're like but the alternative
is just I don't believe anything
and interesting that
you bring up that quote
from my deconstruction story
where I talked about jumping ship
and it was a very dramatic line
and it has been played
in many different videos
that critiqued our deconstruction stories.
There's one of my favorites is
one speaking of Kirk Cameron
by Mr. Ray Comfort who works with Kirk
and he kind of goes through
and breaks down our story
and play some very sentimental music
and almost some like music that
sort of like impending doom
the whole time as we tell our stories
and many things are taken out of context.
It's very entertaining
but one of the things
is that line about I jumped ship
and I took my wife and my children with me
and it's just like, people quote,
like it's so sad, he took his
wife and his children with me.
I think I regret saying,
it was a little bit of
a dramatic thing to say.
I regret saying it because
I think the better analogy
is I jumped out of a ship
and there's not another ship like that
that you're jumping into, right?
But it doesn't mean that
you have no meaning,
you have no purpose and you
have no principles in your life.
Those those things are still intact.
The source and the-
It doesn't mean
that you're drowning.
Yeah, the source and the
philosophical foundation
of those things is coming
from a different place
and it may be a place that
you, as a Christian philosopher
may say it is illegitimate,
I would disagree.
I'm just saying that like it
isn't like I've been swimming
in this ocean of uncertainty
and my family is going nuts
but that's how it was interpreted.
But I mean I agree with what you're saying
in the sense that it's like, all right,
you approach this and there's,
the puzzle pieces are in place.
Like every time you come
around to Christmas,
it's just like we have a puzzle,
we know where the pieces go,
we can sell our kids This is how it works
and then all of a sudden,
you come to the holiday and
it's like the puzzle doesn't,
can't fit together in a
very satisfying way anymore
and so you don't-
The central assertion was
don't forget what matters most.
Yeah.
That was our experience in phase one.
And then in the doubting phase,
well, now, we're talking
about phase three now.
We're still in phase three.
Okay, phase three of you know what,
I haven't replaced that matters most
with something else specifically
but we're just getting through this
and honestly, I'm not suffering,
my family is not suffering.
It's not a horrible experience.
But you're hearing the echoes
of the old Link saying-
But I'm hearing echoes, yes.
There is no meaning here.
This is pointless.
The things that we would
have thought about people
who weren't Christians before
when we were Christians
and you find yourself in
it and you're like, man,
like I still really love my wife.
I still really love my family.
We stand for very similar things.
We're not different people
but we don't know how
to reconcile this story
in the same way
and so you find yourself
becoming the secular person
that you felt sorry for and you're like-
It's about the food, the decorations.
I'm getting through Christmas
on the accoutrement.
Service and family and love.
But in an effort to
transition into stage four,
which is which I don't
like saying stage four
'cause it sounds like cancer.
Phase four.
I actually personally,
again, this is not prescriptive,
I'm not saying this for anybody else.
This is for me.
I actually do find phase three
to be inadequate for me, personally.
So the idea that Christmas
is just about those things,
just about the gift the
giving and the receiving
and the good tidings and
great joy unrelated to Jesus,
just the secular side of things,
just watching "Elf" or seeing
Tim Allen be Santa again,
I do find those things to be inadequate.
Like I didn't wanna be
stuck at phase three.
In other words, I didn't want to become
a completely non-spiritual person
who was like that's all just mumbo-jumbo
and I'm gonna just build my
life on rationality completely
and it's just a natural existence
and that's it and that's,
now, lots of people have done that.
More power to you if that works for you.
For me-
And by the way, people
have to other religions
and then they have, so
then they have new holidays
that they don't have to come to grips
with Christmas on other terms,
they have other holidays
that are in place of it that
have depth of meaning that-
But they're not as good as Christmas.
I'm just kidding.
But something interesting
has happened to me
and I think, I mean it's been happening
over the past few years.
This is not super new but
when we broke the seal
earlier this year.
Boy, when we were telling those stories
about our deconstruction,
we had no idea what the
hell 2020 was gonna bring.
We had no idea that people
were gonna no longer care
about our deconstruction story
as soon as they found out about COVID-19.
Maybe it was a blessing.
I think it was a blessing.
From that perspective.
It's not a blessing for
the world by any means.
but we had a really interesting,
I'm using the word interesting a lot
and I hate the word
interesting so I apologize.
We had a unique perspective on
the way that we would
approach our past faith
for the bulk of our career, right?
We're kind of a like a
little bit embarrassment
about how serious we were
and how far we went in
and the fact that we were missionaries.
I mean not necessarily embarrassment
but like this is gonna
be difficult to explain
and I'm going to say where I'm at now
and so there was almost
an avoidance, a secrecy.
I'm sure some of you who have
been fans for a long time
could sense that.
They're like, "Oh, they
don't talk about their past."
And I think that it
actually influenced the way
that I dealt with it personally.
It inhibited my own personal freedom
to explore spiritual things
because I had such a
weird relationship with it
and I was this public
figure that had this past
that I kind of couldn't explain
and didn't wanna go into the details of
but when we made the
decision to tell the story
in its entirety without apology,
it broke a seal for me, personally.
And it what it did is it kinda,
it was like something
within me got the okay
to be like all right, you can move on now.
You don't have to be in this place.
This is just a guy who
used to be a Christian
and doesn't believe that stuff anymore
and that's who you are,
you can actually move forward
to whatever's next for you
from a spiritual perspective.
And one of the things that has happened
and this is, I don't know where,
I don't know exactly where it's
all going spiritually for me
but I said to him when I told my story
that I had an openness and I did.
I have an openness, I did
and I do currently have an
openness towards spiritual things
and one of the interesting things that,
interesting again, one of
the things that has happened
is sort of a reengaging
with the person of Jesus
in a completely different way and that is
I used to think about anything that,
if I go to the Bible and
I would read something
that Jesus said, again,
I was sort of overwhelmed
with well, let's bring
in the critical lens,
let's bring in the perspective
of the Jesus seminar onto this text.
That's not a fun way to
interact with Jesus, right?
Or a particularly useful way, personally,
when it comes to like your
own personal edification.
There's been a couple of good
books that I've read this year
that I'm not gonna go into
but have sort of changed my perspective
on how I can engage with Jesus,
not as someone who
is God in the flesh
that is the only way to be
reconciled with a vengeful God
who has to punish somebody.
I'm not holding on to any of the old stuff
but just looking at
what Jesus said and did
as a spiritual teacher and being like
there's a lot there, right?
And even engaging in the Christmas story,
not with a preoccupation
about whether or not
it's historically true or based in fact
but is there a truth there to be gleaned?
Is there something that
you and your family
can actually get from interacting with it?
Taking it at face value
without getting into this game
of trying to figure out
whether it's real or not,
which is a little bit ironic
because if you think about
the stories that Jesus,
I mean, first of all Jesus
taught in parable, right?
He taught in story, he told
stories, he made analogies.
And the fact that no one is
ever recorded in the Bible
as responding to one of
the stories that he told
with but did that really happen?
Okay, yeah.
No one was like, "But hold on, hold on.
This thing with the Samaritan,
did that really happen?
Did it happen last week?
Did you see it happen?
'Cause if you didn't see it
happen, I don't believe it."
His point was is that
truth is not, I think,
truth is not something
that is just contained
in this factually historical
verifiable vessel, right?
Truth comes in a lot of different
forms and I can listen to,
I can watch a movie, right?
I can watch a movie that is
from beginning to end, fiction
and still find truth in it.
And I'm not, listen, I'm not saying okay,
the only way I can engage
with the Christmas stories
by just saying it's a
fairy tale and that's it
but I'm saying that if I quit,
if I turn that part of my brain off
that is just constantly trying to judge
whether or not Jesus actually said this
or whether or not this actually happened,
whether or not somebody was
a virgin and got pregnant
and we're just like, let's
set those things aside
because I'm not gonna
reconcile those things.
I mean I have a very strong opinion
about some of those things
and some very strong doubts
but is there a story to be heard there?
Is there a lesson to be learned there?
Is there a truth within this?
And I think that that is very
freeing for me personally.
Does that translate into
like something going into stocking?
I mean, is there a practical,
there doesn't have to
be for like Christmas
and maybe this is,
maybe my question is
revealing about my own issue
which I can get into but,
so maybe it's not a fair question.
Do you even think about it that way?
Like-
No, it's not really what I'm-
Are you saying at Christmas time,
you're reflecting on the story
but you're doing it in a way
that it can be edifying to you,
your interaction with Jesus
can be edifying for you
as opposed to it being something
that you're trying to judge
or tear something down?
Yeah, that.
Because you're either not
gonna interact with Jesus
at Christmas time
or you're gonna have
a negative interaction
or now, you're trying to say
I'm gonna have the positive interaction
that I'm able to have And I'm actually,
I'm at a point where I can have that
and that's what I'm gonna have.
Well, and I think some people would say,
guys, this is where,
this is where the
enlightenment screwed things up
because if you go back
to pre-enlightenment
and pre sort of modern
thinking about things
and pre-rational thought about things,
this is how people engaged
with the stories of Jesus.
There was not a preoccupation
with whether or not these
things happen or not.
There wasn't this
tendency to want to verify
and completely wrap your
mind around these things
but there was a spiritual
interaction with them
and I believe that there
are still many Christians
who would say hey guys,
this is what my faith
looks like right now.
Yeah, I guess
my old mindset creeps in
because it's like the
way I interacted with it
was God became human in order
to save us from ourselves.
Well, even that, okay?
Right, so when we look
at the story of Christmas
from a Christian perspective,
you're right, it's God emptying himself,
becoming a baby, again, I
don't know how this works.
I don't actually believe
that's what was happening
but according to the
story, becomes a baby,
becomes sort of the complete
100% God, 100% human
that then is the only
sacrifice that can be made
in order to reconcile everyone
who will call on the name
of the Lord to God, right?
But isn't there a different way to,
isn't there something else to appreciate
without that having to be true, right?
For instance, since you
mentioned this exact thing
because I was thinking about this earlier.
I don't know the nature of God.
I don't necessarily know
anyone can understand,
grasp or know or talk about
in a understandable way
the nature of God.
I think that there are, if there is a God,
there's probably an experience of that God
is somewhat ineffable, meaning
you cannot communicate it
in a way that would make sense
because it's happening
in a different place
on a different level in a different way
than human language can express.
But the idea that God
would want to be so close
and so involved and so
much a part of humanity
that he would become one of
us is a beautiful concept
that makes me think
about the nature of God
in an open and edifying way.
Does that make sense?
It doesn't have to have
happened as described
for me to be like that,
in the way, I'm glad
we talked about music.
I didn't know that's what's gonna happen
but a song resonates with you.
There's something about-
In a soul level.
There's something about
music that you connect with
and you wouldn't say that song is true
and that song is false but
you would be like this song,
I feel like I begin to actually
resonate and synchronize with this music
because it connects with
my soul and this doesn't.
I feel like that can
happen with a story as well
and so, for me, there
are elements of that idea
because I mean, if anything,
the concept of God being in everything
and God being available within someone,
the universe, the fabric of the universe
being whatever you wanna call it,
that's something that's
still very intriguing to me
that I wanna be open to
and I wanna lean into
and I feel like I can find
that in the story of Christmas.
That's all I'm saying.
I think our former selves
would be saying right now,
I mean, you just can't,
you can't invent, you
can't just invent the terms
with which you interact with Jesus.
I mean, you're missing the point.
You're just inventing a new
way to interact with Jesus
that is just picking and
choosing what you want
that's gonna be inspirational for you.
I think that's what our former selves
would've said.
Of course,
that's what I would've said.
But I don't think,
and it doesn't matter
what anybody's saying.
I think for you, you're making a decision
because I do think that
the decision has been,
is there gonna be any
interaction with Jesus, you know?
Or am I just gonna move on
and say that was in my past.
Having being spiritually
open, I think, is,
I hear, that's what I
see in what you're saying
that like you're choosing
to approach Jesus
in a way that you can.
And who is anybody to argue with that?
Even if they think you
may be missing the point
or doing it wrong.
Well, think about "Close
Encounters of the Third Kind".
Let's keep going with this music thing.
I'm really glad you
brought it up because...
I don't know if you've seen the movie.
Seen the movie?
I've heard about it.
I've seen images from it.
So, the way that they
communicate with the alien beings
is in the form of music because music,
again, represents this
ineffable thing that's happening
on a different level of consciousness
that the language barrier
between whatever they would speak,
in whatever we would speak can't,
we find music and that's
how we communicate, right?
I think that's a beautiful picture
because I do wanna address the criticism
that our former selves would make.
Of course, my former self would be like,
dude, you're just a new age bullshitter
that just thinks whatever he wants to.
And there is absolutely
nothing that I can say
to convince that person who thinks that
that that's not what's happening
but what I would tell
my former self is that
I think that there is a preoccupation
with categorizing and systematizing
the deepest truths of the universe
in a way to make them
understandable and applicable
and there is some merit in that
but what I'm trying to be open to
is the idea that whatever God is
can be something that I can experience
without having to turn
around and explain it
and categorize it and be able
to recreate it and package it
and write it down and
speak it to someone else.
And I think that,
ironically, I think that some
of the things that Jesus said
when you kinda come to some of the things
that he said from a fresh perspective
seemed to indicate that he was hinting
at some of those things
along with a lot of
other religious leaders
who've lived and said similar
things, the Buddha being one.
Ultimately, what I'm saying
is I have found it to
be especially freeing
to take that post-enlightenment,
human has to figure everything out hat off
and be like what is it
like to engage with God
in the way that I would
engage with the ocean?
I don't go into the ocean and ride a wave
and preoccupy myself with the
physics of what's happening.
I just do it.
I just experience it, right?
And I think if there is a God
that God is probably like that.
And so, when I think
about the Christmas story,
yes, it is something
that somebody wrote down
2,000 years, ago.
Yes, it is something that does get down
into some very particular
truths about things
but what is it like to read a story
that has that kind of significance
and that kind of staying power
and read it from a fresh perspective
with taking that hat off?
What kind of new things will you see?
Well, one thing you'll see
is okay, I'm looking at Mary
and Joseph in a different way.
I'm thinking about the fact
that this is a pregnant woman
who isn't married who is seeking refuge.
How relevant is that in the
world that we're in right now?
That draws out my empathy,
not only for them,
but for people who might
be currently in our world,
in our society dealing
with the same things
and I don't have to just focus
on the but is this the Son of God period?
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
You can find new things in it.
Yeah, so I definitely see
how as you describe this phase for you
that it's how you're
practically approaching
the spiritual openness
that we both talked about
at the end of our stories.
So, I appreciate hearing it as
it's food for thought for me
as I continue to,
to aim for spiritual openness myself
because that is important to me.
I think when when you
describe your tendency
to wanna judge the Bible
and like going against that tendency
in order to move towards openness
and a spiritual experience,
for me, I think the task
that I'm working with
is it's judgment as well
but it's a judgment on myself.
And I'm on a journey.
I think that's where I'm at in my journey,
I think a lot of it comes up at Christmas
that I've alluded to that like it's
trying to move past self-judgment
because that's how I,
that was my interaction,
a lot of my interaction
with how I came up, right?
So it's shedding that judgment
so that I can actually have
an open and honest spiritual pursuit.
And I'll leave it at that at this point
but I think that that's where I'm at.
Yeah.
Again, I'm very grateful
to be where I'm at.
I'm happy to be on this journey.
I don't feel that I'm
flailing or are struggling.
I don't have a tremendous amount of,
I'm not battling with doubt
just because those questions come up
around Christmas time again.
I would not characterize
it that way but it's,
I want to be answering the question
and continuing to make positive progress
in my spiritual journey
and so part of that is
shedding the self-judgment
and understanding
when that comes into play
and kinda putting that in its place.
Yeah, 'cause I mean it's not easy.
I don't have the same exact hang ups
but it's not easy for me, right?
Because I feel like I
stagnated for quite some time
and it's weird that it took
us talking about it for me to
be like hey, I can pick up a
Richard Rohr book and read it
and know that we don't
exactly agree on everything
but the way he talks about
Jesus is again, it resonates.
And if I remove that judgment,
that okay, well, but I got to figure out
how this lines with this system.
No, I don't.
I don't have to figure that out.
And who is God?
Who am I to think that
God has to be categorized
or even understood?
And so,
I don't know.
I can't,
I can't turn around and tell you what,
and you being anyone
listening, what you should do
because I can't tell me what I should do.
It's a disposition, right?
It's a leaning in an openness more so
than it is a this is the prescribed path.
And it just feels very different
and I'm sorry when I get into it
when the things I say don't make sense
but I kind of feel like
that's the point, right?
The closer I get to it, the
more I can't talk about it.
Okay, well, and we don't have
to talk about it anymore.
So, I mean if that's the phase, that's it.
Then we've gone through them.
Maybe there's another phase.
Who knows, man?
Phase five.
Okay, let us know-
You got a recommendation?
I do.
Before we wrap that
conversation up though,
just let us know your experience
in whatever phase you're currently in.
#EarBiscuits.
How you think about
Christmas and the holidays.
I do have a rec and I may
have talked about this
at some point but the website that I use
for a lot of my meat tips.
Oh!
Amazingribs.com.
We got a left turn.
It's not really a left turn
because it goes back to
I really wanna do like
a standing rib roast
because I think that's a great-
Amazingribs.com. That's Meathead.
It's Meathed.
Meathead Goldwyn, I guess, is his name.
And this dude is just the authority
when it comes to barbecue
and again it's Amazing Ribs
'cause he started, I guess,
with telling people how to make
ribs but it runs the gamut.
You wanna know how to smoke,
bake, brine a turkey, whatever?
Any kind of piece of meat,
you wanna know exactly
how you should do it
from a scientific standpoint.
I mean he has like a a chemist
or somebody that he consults
like a local professor
who goes into the details
of like this is a myth.
You don't need to do this
but you do need to do this
and here's why you need to do it.
And so for someone who wants to appreciate
sort of the technical side
of making mari with meat,
it's a lifesaver and he
has incredible recipes
and I'm hoping to follow at
least one of them for Christmas
and you will be the
receiver of that bounty.
Yes!
Amazingribs.com
Happy holidays!
Merry Christmas.
We'll be catching next week.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget
to click on the circular
icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.